[rock music]
GORDON RAMSAY:
[inaudible],, you are crazy.
OK.
Lasso.
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): Over 30
years of working
as a chef has all
been leading to this moment--
catching a Peruvian
cactus worm with a lasso.
Una, dos, tres.
Ah.
Yeah.
[laughter]
GORDON RAMSAY: Hey, Haresh.
I'm going to kill you.
You gotta get up here first.
Oh, man.
Oh!
[laughter]
Excuse me, that is not
funny.
Be careful.
GORDON RAMSAY: This
is super dangerous.
Uno, dos, tres.
Oh!
Yeah!
[laughter]
Si!
Si, si, si!
[inaudible]
[speaking spanish]
Hey, good job.
[laughter]
Look at that.
Seriously?
[bleep]
[music playing]
Going to be delicious.
I'm proud of you.
[inaudible]
Ay, yay, yay.
They're like
giant caterpillars.
How did he first
learn about these?
[inaudible] Excellent.
And how old were
you when you first
started dangling off
the side of a cliff
with your dad looking for worms?
Six or seven.
Amazing.
I'm just going to get
them a little bit dry,
just so it doesn't crackle.
OK, go.
[sizzling]
Whoa!
[bleep]
You OK?
[laughter]
Oh, bravo!
Thank you.
GORDON RAMSAY: Stop it.
[laughter]
It's like a--
it's like a crispy, uh--
like a crispy cockroach.
[laughter]
[music playing]
The taste was crispy
to begin with-- fine.
However, the inside?
Nah.
No bueno.
But this is how they survived
so remotely-- protein
growing literally in a cactus.
So an amazing secret,
and a big eye-opener.